according to nist
cloud computing is a model for enabling
ubiquitous convenient
on-demand network access
to a shared pool of configurable
computing resources
for example networks servers storage
applications and services
that can be rapidly provisioned and
released
with minimal management effort
or service provider interaction
let us understand this definition
by focusing on a few key words
ubiquitous means irrespective of any
type of web-enabled device
or any type of network
such as ethernet
ppp
foc
etc
we can access the services subscribed
from the service provider
cloud computing takes the technology
services and applications that are
similar to those on the internet
and turns them into a self-service
utility
the latest version of nist definition
states that cloud computing networks
must use virtualization
and multi-tenancy
it also states that the customer must be
able to provision his or her resources
with minimal management effort
and service providers interaction
this means customer can access the
resource subscribed from anywhere and
anytime
in the next slide we will discuss
essential characteristics of cloud
computing
nist states that there are five
essential characteristics which are
achieved by the service providers
so that they can call their service as
cloud service
the five essential characteristics are
on-demand self-service
rapid elasticity measured service
resource pooling
and broad network access
let's understand each characteristic one
by one in the coming slides
the next slide will introduce us to the
concept of on-demand self-service
on-demand self-service means that a
client can provision computer resources
without the need for interaction with
the cloud service provider personnel
the customer gets the complete privilege
to select the resources and decide its
quantity based on their business process
without any formal consultation with the
service provider
the customer can access the dedicated
portal anytime and from anywhere
however
he needs to comply with the limitation
of regulatory concern
to perform changes in configuration of
the current setup
the customer can upgrade or downgrade
services anytime
also the upgrade or downgrade of
resources is committed in just a few
seconds
in the following slide we will discuss
rapid elasticity